all right here we are is a black panther
I don't know where this morning they
were like here's the Black Panther
poster then you're going to get a black
panther trailer bunny I first saw the
Black Panther post over oh yeah king of
Wakanda 50 people on my Twitter like it
looks photoshopped it looks weird and I
saw it on my computer I was like it does
look weird it looks like an actual
picture of chadwick boseman face on a
CGI bottom you can't make CGI it look
okay for pictures comes a little weird
but I got a trailer the Black Panther
looks pretty kick-ass it starts up Andy
Serkis aka claw is talking to Martin
Freeman's character Paul has no arm and
so I was always wondering about that
I'll try and smacked his arm and
apparently he lost his arm I was like
there's no blood for someone who didn't
lost an arm like bloodlessly lost his
arm he's like what do you know about
what Conan Martin Freeman zygors Thurber
old country neat outfits whatever we
find out it's all up front
El Dorado is actually in Africa didn't
sit in it no one really knows about I
have to assume that's what they're
saying
otherwise it's something else could be
El Dorado is a big golden idol that
turns people into ravenous raging zombie
monsters interesting they're talking
about a hidden city because there's a
lot of imagery in here they're like I
don't recognize this in the world that I
live in look of it is amazing it's like
African culture meets the 22nd century
it's very futuristic in here and I love
that line in here where you hear someone
saying and I assume they're talking to
chadwick boseman where's like you're a
good man with a good heart but it's hard
for a good man to be king I really want
them to explore that because the scene
where these dudes they got the guns and
you look up you see Black Panther he
just kicks the [ __ ] out of him like
that's the easy part of his job I'm a
good guy I'm a hero I'm Black Panther
those are bad guys they have gonna kick
the [ __ ] out of them easy however when
you're King things get more complicated
I want to see that I want to see his
leadership I want to see that conflict
this is a very unique scenario it's the
king of a country who is a superhero
he's not eccentric billionaires were
crazy to do what they're doing this guy
is the leader of the country who is
Black Panther and it looks like you have
your conflict that dude doesn't look
like he's messing around
I believe it's supposed to be men eight
there was actually a little bit of a
rumors like they're not going to have
man April's any of that in the
because it's razors which I find absurd
and ridiculous I doubt they're going to
call him man 8 because that's just a
dorky s title like hey man 8 yes 1971
what it's just a dated title but if I'm
looking at the visuals of it I have to
assume that's mayonnaise which again the
easy part is he's a villain Black
Panther is a good guy I put the suits on
in the fight but what are the politics
rap into that that I assume they're
going to touch on because this is a very
unique scenario where the leader of a
country is also a superhero that's the
unique perspective we have with Black
Panther when you release a poster of him
sitting on a throne with the body of the
superhero in the head of the King there
really doesn't send a message as to what
you're going to see in this movie I hope
it doesn't fall short of that all right
guys the Black Panther trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what are you hoping to see in Black
Panther whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]